hey everybody what's up welcome stream
coca oh my god it's been how many years
best is it been about 600 years since
we've done stream cocoa but we're back
and we're super excited because we got a
special guest marina Franklin everybody
marina Franklin you might you might
possibly know her from a million shows
from doing amazing stand-up but also
from our Conan con yea shows we did four
shows on the roof you're hilarious and
they sent you into the belly of the
beast every day yeah but it wasn't
beastly it was fun well see that's
that's why she's great because she says
it's fun I say it was like a hellscape I
would see it for me it would be like
every morning we'd be sending you off
he'd be like well we may never see them
again you know it's like sending you off
to war and you would come back happy I
was so happy there were people telling
me they've never seen me happier that's
amazing oh my god I was like not even my
new relationship they're like what's
that thing on her face it's a smile
that's what it is she's very happy well
we're excited you're on the show tonight
which is fantastic you were you were on
the up and up show last night you are
all over team Coco you're holding us up
you're lifting us up thank goodness me
so we need some help and we finally
finally um so today we're gonna play you
know you're a big gamer I am Marie was
just telling me before we started you
wanna you mind sharing the little call
of duty story you just shared with me
which is hilarious well yeah I used to
play call of duty on my computer oh that
with the keyboard and I want all you PC
people to hear this she's a real gamer
she plays on PC alright don't give me
crap in the chance it was really because
I just didn't have
like I didn't have the money for don't
qualify it that's great but then I come
wear it it's very special about playing
on a keyboard and the screen being like
right here in my face I love it and so I
was up playing like Call of Duty for at
least about an hour when my boyfriend
who was over on my bed he goes what are
you doing who is the guy in this
relationship that's right exactly
oh people are commenting also on my
glasses yeah I didn't do the thing I
didn't schedule my contacts correctly so
I'm kind of between contacts right now
so I get the old man glasses that's
right you can see how blind I am look
how blind I am and dirty by the way
gross they've got you oh they got me by
the cojones
yeah the chicharones that's actually
[Music]
okay I'm just wearing a different
languages all right we're playing dead
cells today that's right I know we're
doing it hey Dixie what's up
she's a PC that can play co diva can't
afford a ps4 we have a ps4 now I have
one knows she's got one now everything's
great now that's right Conan veep's
I don't think you babes unless you don't
know it vapes means if you think vapes
means reads books about history then yes
he babes oh yeah yeah I guess so I
people have a lot of theories about
Conan but guys if Conan did vape what
flavor would Eve ake I'll leave your
answer in the chat
all right marina here we go you gotta
give him something you know peach
cobblers delicious dead cells were
playing that's right salt assault AMA
I'm gonna get rekt old man that's right
schmitter I am gonna get rekt I'm
obsessed with this game it's super fun
so here's the deal it's a side scroller
we're gonna die a good jillion times
that's a that's a scientific prediction
good jillion times okay every time you
die you start back at the beginning it's
gonna hurt us in our work but the fun
thing is you do get some kind of
permanent upgrades so we will gonna get
better as we go along okay also I'm
forcing you to play my personal game so
you're gonna help me get better at this
game you've been playing it but you're
but you're also already not told yeah
eight hours on Sunday I have no life
shocker to no one all right let's get
into it so hey I guess
there we go continue yeah now just to
set the scene for you marina we are a
you know what here I'm gonna do because
this is gonna be a cool animation you're
gonna see here in a second restart yeah
here we go we're like a goop
we're like a like a fungal good adds
nothing we're like we're like this weird
fungal goop and then we go over this is
great I love this and we can animate
this dead body look at this yes right
fungal goop so RB you're gonna pick up
the gold from last time so basically
here's how it goes a is gonna be jump X
is gonna be your one one weapon y will
be another one the triggers will be
other ones will go through this don't
work very simple so go a let's go over
to the right and you can double jump to
in the air so you can hit any twice
Danni Madison says like Dark Souls but a
bit friendlier that's true so these are
all kind of the power-ups we've got so
this is we gotta fill them all up at
some point we won't be filling them off
in the stream every one but eventually
so keep going to the right coning veep's
fungal goop duper on xbl I think you're
right I see ya go down here now we're
gonna get our weapons alright so RB
let's grab that and then our other
daggers RB these are random every time
and we can't grab the shield oh I mean
you can grab the she'll if you are you a
shield what kind of a kind of a game
player are you do you'll are you just
did that yeah this is my this is my
emotionally this is how I am on dates
I'm like how are you how are you would
you like a drink
well I'm not a shield player but I want
to play how you want to play do you are
you like a sniper what's your I mean I'm
a sniper all right all right
the shield is always interesting okay
games I haven't played this one in a
while so I'm gonna say from gamer to
gamer get rid of the shield Barbie just
heart be it Barbie it yeah so and then
go to the right go to the right go to
the other right yeah yeah and then hit a
more replacing yeah all right now we're
ready to go so X is gonna be your dagger
melee weapon y is gonna be your throwing
daggers okay all right look I just did a
non gamer thing I went where's the ax
you did a human thing you did let's see
what are they saying
ah that's right where's Conan I don't
know and I also don't know how to say
your name because there's a lot of
non-english letters in there this Conan
really do his hair with frothy royal
turkey blood my first question is what
is royal turkey blood is there a turkey
that's like in charge of a country yeah
no he uses a combination of mayonnaise
and powdered sugar everybody knows that
it's on the Wikipedia do your homework
there we go
read by nature says dead cells souls of
Persian this is actually or you have I
did mayonnaise like in high school did
you have gum in your hair and you were
trying to get up I don't know I just
someone said to try it how did it go I
smell like egg salad delicious
I wish I smelled like egg salad by the
way apologies for my breath which I'm
sure is like heavy on the Starbucks no
not true
alright let's go let's go go through
this door you can also smash the doors
don't worry about this door we're gonna
get to the get to the right get some bad
guys I heard about beer in the Harrises
bin clunk I don't know you could know
you could go up there probably a bit so
that's gonna let us we'll unlock those
as we go through and it'll let us
teleporter on the levels oh yeah here we
go
never played this game before you're
gonna do great
we're a fungus in the in a dead body
with a bunch of daggers what could go
wrong there dicks just yeah cut him up
cut him up also be is gonna help your
role also don't be discouraged we're
gonna die a thousand gajillion times
that's what's gonna happen
now you could press lb to heal press and
hold lb you drink your flask by the way
that's how I feel every time I get a
coffee that's right
waffle charts ask marina any games that
have pleasantly surprised you in the
last few years what are you playing
right now are you playing anything now
are you in there yeah god yes
during Conan yeah my god that's why God
Jerry Konig Kahn marina said gods of war
by accident you know it's a live stream
things happen can't blame her she knows
it's god of work she said gods of yes
and then I was like I need to play this
game yes and I didn't really pay
attention to like whether it's singular
or plural that's well I guess that
doesn't make me an extreme gamer but I
do love that game you said one wrong
thing you're angry yeah
what I should have said was goddess of
war yeah see that's the way to do it
goddess yeah why's it gotta be God of
War yo get with the program um yeah God
of War it's amazing God of War is
amazing it's addictive so addictive and
I love that he has yeah oh my god trait
no not a tray you that's really what's
the kid's name somebody help me out
what's the kid's name of god of war I
didn't call this gamer on it and then
after every clueless gamer my mind is
like an etch-a-sketch in it just a
racist God support of the sequel's is
Richard yes PC Sam
Falkor well played them click Dylan says
you should play I don't know what that
is
I love you too code code
lagger I'm sorry I seen your name Ron
retro-gaming keep up the good streaming
thanks y'all
yeah this is Metroidvania like yeah so
this game I am obsessed with it so again
like here's the things I like about this
game first of all you're a fungus in a
dead body how does it get cooler than
that yeah right really cool and weird
creative creative and they're also you
don't have to go up there let's I would
go climb that chain and then climb the
old chain aru and then you can roll by
be hitting beat and then so down in a
we'll get you down there yeah nice
you're pretty good with those daggers
yeah you are not
there's no effing around your attempts
or your fungus in a dead body love that
every time you play a level it's
different it's like what's called
procedurally generated have you heard
about that so it's like random every
time so like if when if you die I'm
sorry if you die and I have to play the
level be totally different like oh it's
all yeah every time just cool so it
won't look it'll look different but the
platforms will be in different places so
it keeps it interesting yeah at Reyes
thank you mom okay I think the lure in
the Conan O'Brien series is really good
honestly that dr. Thornton fungus in my
house I guess in my house there Florida
wrestling yes the documentary Conan
can't stop is super fun and you could
see me 90 pounds heavier in that
documentary cuz I play the masturbating
bear on tour
alright see ya perfect this game looks
like something called the quest for
victory in my opinion court petty I
don't know that I've played that
question victory do you know the first
game you ever played in or the first
video game you ever played it was
the ball that goes back and forth Bhopal
is that what is yeah oh man cluttering
up love it I was like a kid love pot it
was in black and white yeah awesome
yeah I remember playing a game with like
two squiggly things that were supposed
to be like gunfighters and it was like
it was similar where I was like they'd
shot a bullet it was like doink doink oh
yeah
yeah I was like a weird and Gallic is a
Galaga Oh Galaga yeah here's an inch of
Galaga
I'm mastered on some level Galaga mass
so there's a rhythm to that there was a
rhythm to it maybe for uni usually it's
just like and I couldn't get out oh my
god that was that that was that time and
my cousins were like what is she like
it's just mad and then that's it but
you're like that's like good the Good
Will Hunting guy's saying like yeah math
is just you know like it's like when
Beethoven had a piano for people like me
normal idiots it's not just bad it's not
it's true I feel like I'm not going
anywhere I would go down and go down and
go to the left the left I'd say go that
way is that our little map over there
there's that no I would go down keep
going keep going down down a doughnut
yeah there you go down a over that thing
boom go up over that way first game you
played was cookie factory
oh you're doing it I would uh I keep
going I think yeah climb up there I say
so go through his dumb door just smash
it up oh yeah
that's by the way how I go through doors
in real life I'm just like ya know what
I'm doing I just play yes that's a real
game you're killing it though I think I
think if you start reading manuals
yeah what do you learn oh no this isn't
the waiting another story boyfriend look
at you you're like oh where do we go now
I say go down and back here I'll get you
to a place
I'll get you I'm gonna get you they tell
the story about the boyfriend so I was
playing doom love doom but I knew that
and I didn't tell my boyfriend at the
time I had we have been playing it for a
while uh-huh oh god get on I'm sorry
sorry so you're on God mode he has no
idea he had no idea and he was very like
he just what did I do
are you okay you're good oh I'm sorry my
bad so he was like no way oh my god I
was freaking out I was like I know I'm
so good I was like watch this good I'm
gonna do that that's a great trick but
the thing was I got to see the level of
the game that I would never have
achieved on my own I was like like how
can anyone get through this game I mean
the way they were coming at me and I was
like so that was amazing that's
incredible I gotta say like she did that
I got a dude that's a brilliant I got to
do that check that's good cuz I just
embarrass myself now by Dylan I'd go
down and then there's guys that are just
gonna be crazy playing video games in
knowing Conan best job in the world
except for marina great job number 8
you're gonna be in Pittsburgh tomorrow
yes oh that's a Pittsburgh yes
Pittsburgh Comedy Festival it's pretty
Comedy Festival and and how long are you
gonna be that all you to be there I'm
gonna be there until so Thursday and
Friday that's tomorrow
yeah nice and have you been to
Pittsburgh before I have never been guys
if you are in Pittsburgh er have been
tell marina where to go and what to do
because it's our first time in
Pittsburgh
yeah now you're Pittsburgh it's like
amazing like my friend John Muller lives
there oh really great yeah yeah I've
never oh these guys are I these guys the
worst
get rid of that guy
Goliath pug says so I suck at this game
like for real the farthest I've gotten
in three days is the castle paid that's
all right man RB RB well thanks Richard
that's very nice you say uh Schmidt I
love clueless gamer which is something
we do on the show I wish I was as good
at video games since when I was young
still better than average person but man
you're so much better when you're young
you are you want you're not afraid you
don't think like is this person gonna
sue me if I hit them your own mortality
hasn't set in yet which makes it harder
to play video game Emma hey what's up
hey Emma Emma helped us out of that coma
conscious so speaking of shields this
dude has a shield yeah I would put yeah
get behind him and knock him around oh
you got this get behind his emotional
armor this is good practice for
relationships you got to get inside and
really process you yeah this is V that
guy with the shield is me I don't let
anybody in single til I'm dead hey TJ
mom jeez what's up I got this you got
this yeah nice I also love that
exploding door whose car that's right
Conor McGregor's gotta get on Conan
coming up before his next fight last
interview with Daniel Cormier was great
Ronda Rousey just want some fake
wrestling belt by still better some
kumquats
yeah Conor McGregor's one of our
favorite guests he's really I mean not
just cuz he's Irish but he's very
entertaining you know Conor McGregor in
the UFC
he's like a UFC fighter and he's this
tiny Irish guy but just huge personality
oh I always talking crap like he's
amazing and he I think he came on Beth
was it the last time at the time before
he did this like spin kick
we're like Conan like held something and
he kicked it like Adam became like like
on the game no in real life oh man in
real life was like this is a bad example
but like this oh like close to Conan's
face really it was me
but yeah we love guests like that that's
incredible
speaking of guess we're gonna Franklin's
on the show tonight y'all make sure to
watch it Maryna then yes how them
shorties act wrong where the shorties at
what was the thing what a shorties where
the shorties watch it I love it what our
stories watching um you may have seen me
on okay I don't think oh my god well you
should know her from Conan Kahn at least
if you guys are real fans yep you ever
heard of that show it was a show that's
amazing in the WAC Arnold sketch where
the girl goes yeah you smell like french
fries how is it being on the set of that
show I mean it must be did you know at
the time it was gonna become such an
iconic amazing not at all
yeah really that's you just it was just
your Chapelle show you over in her
clothes back I go I'd go up there that's
good
oh you got it you got it it's gonna make
you more powerful you just pick one of
these things I say pick red today that's
crazy tality isn't crew yes another
thing that happens when you're bleeding
a bit little bit of blood happening
there Oh hold lb yeah coffee but yeah
that's so cool you're on the spot so
that's like a you know it's like one of
the greatest show will go down in
history and has already gone down was
one of the greatest shows of all time
yeah he's so cool and he always comes up
to me and he goes hey he's um he's my
french fries he does his own line that
he wrote I love it that's good yeah cuz
he worked at McDonald's saved a day so
he had
girls I would make fun of him when he
would come home because he was like
happy that he had a job at McDowell made
fun of him for smell like french fries
hey by the way who makes fun of french
fries smell delicious I wish I could
smell as good as french fries instead I
have to smell like Old Spice captain El
Capitan or something terrible I would
kill the smell like french fries
Chapelle call me tell me how did about
the french fries thing yeah actually
done I'll just get a job at McDonald's I
was in a movie trainwreck if you guys
watched that love trainwreck how was
that with John Cena
I hear he's like the nicest guy ever I
think John Cena holds the record for
fulfilling the most make-a-wish wishes
he's done like five hunt like he's like
and he the way he's like 300 ahead of
anyone else which is like crazy all
those WWE people we've had a bunch of
them on here are the nicest professional
great people I know what about what
about me what about me though oh wow wow
wow they're near a lot about marina
terrible liar
terrible liar emotionally look at your
tiny though on the real screen you're
tired of it and this jacket I'm in love
and Murray's jacket thank you girl
sounds like french fries yeah my gaming
jacket God what are the bet what's your
favorite french fries
give a favorite fry well I like the
truffle fries that's a weakness mmm
I can only eat those after all before
8:00 okay after 12:00 cuz I'm doing
intermittent fasting oh wait how is that
going it's good this is not like a
stream question that's like a real
question we'll be real here okay I'm
very interested intermittent fasting
guys this is just gonna spiral down feel
like quiet like questions about
nutrition well like nutrition likes to
you I will say eat your carrots no food
you don't care you smell like carrots I
know you
okay eating carrots it's healthy
nutritious you don't have to ever leave
the screen intermittent fasting is
actually good too because you only eat
through 12 to 8 for me okay I already
can't do it but go on
and you have a lot of energy really and
I work out I'm like you know yeah I have
a like strong you got it going on you
know right now because there's too much
there's a lot but there's there's some
there's some there's some iron
underneath all these bedazzles yeah and
emotionally strong don't forget oh stop
it
good let's get her in the small box
again she there we go Lord your toys are
so tight here like this big people can't
tell uh I love you should try to make
french fries yourself from scratch
I do have an air fryer I got an air
fryer recently highly recommend really
it's supposed to make like fried foods
but healthy it's like you can cut up
potatoes put them in there it'll make it
fried but fries without oil I've never
done that
I've only cooked salmon in it and my
apartment smells so much like it's
disgusting
cats I don't thank God also I think a
single guy with cats is a serial killer
a hundred percent serial killer I'm
sorry I'm sorry I don't cigarettes or
cats no oh no no no cats plural if you
come over to my house and I have two
cats you're gonna be like I'm gonna be
murdered tonight there's no way no no I
would just think you're sensitive
creature oh well that's very kind of you
say correct correct
you needed two cat now what about if I
have two Turtles
no see serial killers don't like animal
okay
threat you know all fairy killers right
they would never
they wouldn't have this you're right
good point you know now what about my
stuffed animal collection now that just
means psychologically you haven't
matured how can you tell
playing video games on the counter or 64
sir I hate to be to play into I know I'm
an immature fool but can I just say
something not safe for work can I say
something doesn't this look like a dick
flying through the air with rainbows
behind it only if you see it that way
well I saw it that way immediately after
I put it on now that you put it there
yeah it does right I'm so sorry but
there's any tape over there let me know
I'll put it over my shirt guys I'm sorry
terrible yeah it's the worst it's the
worst all right let's keep going or we
all have a few more myths for marina
Franklin so get your questions in now
get your questions in now we're usually
great by the way here we go thank you
thank you I'm covering this shirt up
just for the sake of if we can't have
you this is a family stream how would I
put this can you cover this up for me to
make it more decent for the stream cuz
this is see doesn't I will say it kind
of looks like you know like it's flying
through the air all right so let's let's
make it more safe for work if people are
watching this it works you tell me you
want your the fashionista here I don't
wear a shirt so whatever it may be okay
so then they're not really sure perfect
but just looks like you're a corridor
okay there we go
yeah see now this is a family shirt it's
giant Oh crazy thing going on
which way she look great are you want to
keep putting you live a few more minutes
you want to keep playing first of all
this acknowledges the fact that I died I
was deceased for a second oh but I'm
gonna I'm gonna chalk it up to me
distracting you the entire time your
play now to be fair I was talking to the
entire time yay when she's not fair it's
not fair how much I I actually do like
this game I was like oh that's right I
was like come on this game is great you
I'm serious when I say this is my
favorite game in the last few years
I love no it's really fun and she's
super cheap if I get this game yes oh my
god there we go there's that there's
that so that's that's you know what you
just got to see whether you want to
place dead cells or not you have to want
it I have none of those things career
life that's or a boyfriend or girl you
have but I have dead cells
I have dead cells and I have you guys
and I have you guys and this penis shirt
cover 64 shirt that's all I have well
you know cuz I was seeing with them no
it's not a penis anymore but it was I
did I did have a Commodore 64 oh god I
wish I have no rhythm but I do have a
there's a lost member of the Commodores
it's right here right here
and this is 64th Commodore there other
that's a some guy reviewed this game and
now he doesn't have a career oh snap
better view exactly uh on the go it's oh
yeah it's out on its I think this is out
for all platforms on a switch
I think it's on PlayStation 2 yeah and
it just came out a few weeks ago and
it's amazing oh these are all the runes
I have I got a bunch of runes like
because the cool thing is you do die
every single time to go back to the
beginning we're doing a daily challenge
oh here we go like this
alright what's you die you're done then
that's it I just die no you're
know you're gonna do a quick daily
challenge every day they have a new
challenge you like get stuff so this
will be perfect
cuz you got to leave in a few minutes no
I'm not saying you're gonna die in a few
minutes kind of she's going back out you
got to go back in I believe in you
morena you could do this it's different
each time right hey Kimmy show what's up
yes she's pretty dope I agree Marina is
pretty dope Commodore is a bird condors
a bird a Commodore is a rank in like an
army or something oh boy and the zoo
that's getting down you got to pick one
of these weapons and then get down I've
heard monsters get nastier and nastier
as you get closer to the end oh yeah
that's because Oh Joe Joe says the
reviewer does have a career because he
plagiarized from another reviewer don't
plagiarize guys also a review how are
you gonna plagiarize a review isn't it
just your thoughts about something just
play a video game and tell us your
thoughts how are you to plagiarize a
review it's not like it's a Navy they
didn't have they had the same emotion
that's when they were like let me just
use his words did you ever cheat in
school be honest
did you never I could never really I'm
not a good my face doesn't lie okay so
the teacher would see that I was
cheating yeah yeah dad how are you a
poker bad poker fighter to invite her to
your poker games guys if you want to win
money I'm just telling you I'm a like it
said frozen-yogurt 175 percent damage of
frozen yogurt that's what it does to
your gut oh my god I just took 175
damage to my abs okay marina will be on
Conan yeah
launcher tonight and go to the
Pittsburgh comedy festival tomorrow and
I'll be doing an hour in Chicago at the
Vic Theatre oh that's exciting hour yeah
two hours back-to-back seven o'clock and
9:30 anyway Theatre in Chicago you're a
warrior and what is that that is I don't
know
September 14 oh my god that's how long
did it take for you to get together in
that hour no it's great September 14th
of The Vic Theatre in Chicago you could
go to marina Franklin calm yes if you
want to free tickets I love it do it and
we got us a good vibe you got to let you
go you got him to go do the show I got a
good show I gotta go be funny marina
Franklin calm for all your marina
Franklin needs watcher at the Vic
Theatre in Chicago in September in
Pittsburgh she's coming at you tomorrow
in the next few days and tonight on
Conan watch you're in Franklin everybody
[Music]
ready I'm so sweaty I'm so sweaty I'm so
sorry I'm so sweaty that's right all
right have fun of the show everybody
watched tonight um we'll see you later
Jackie yeah we got another half hour to
go we're back I love
oh my god we should can we start it do I
have to go up before I want to play more
I'm gonna get yelled at if you don't go
oh we're making Marina marina where is
she just break a leg Marina people are
saying thank you I love it don't really
break a leg though who knows you're
doing a lot of traveling in the future
All Right see you later
Gilligan sit right all right guys here
we get a list I'm gonna be asking you
guys I'm obsessed with this game it's
amazing and we're gonna kill a lot of
bad guys so that's what we're doing
gotta grind away just give her the game
link to twitch I wish I could I would
love to all right the game addictions
starting I did play this game for eight
hours on Sunday I did play it until 4:00
in the morning two nights ago
that's me and it's the goop just joining
us
you just missed marina Franklin we're
playing dead cells
it's a plat it's kind of a I guess it's
called a rogue games like blood-borne
where you kind of have perma death are
called roguelike games I think and but
you the thing the thing about this game
is you kind of you do get some permanent
upgrades which is good so you kind of
grind through the game the goop is
richard hyung well you kind of grind
through the game which is great let me
go tactics
those guys by the way these guys I hate
the most
there's there's a fun thing where you
can look at all the stats and things
that have killed you and those zombies
are the things that kill me the most so
I kill those the game's called dead
cells because you're kind of collecting
these cells and that's how you kind of
upgrade yourself so and so those blue
things are cells and those are what and
again the thing is if you can make it to
the next level you get to keep your
cells and that's kind of how you upgrade
yourself Oh Godzilla sixty seven twenty
eight you just got your shoutout thank
you for watching
yes and so last night if you live in Los
Angeles we've been doing this live show
called up and up hosts I'm out of Moses
storm our pal and Conan showed up last
night which was super fun it's a monthly
show at the dynasty typewriter theater
is that Echo Park
no it's MacArthur Park I guess and and
yeah Conan showed up marina did the show
last night it's kind of a fun variety
show I guess there's a bit of an
interview pass guests have included Nick
Kroll Pete Holmes who else am I not
thinking of a thousand people but
definitely come out and how do they how
do they find tickets to that I guess
[Music]
okay thank you stay tuned those guys
these guys
[Music]
oh boy my favorite thing is O'Malley
screwing with ya
are they not are they reading this
chatter twitch chat we're reading both
chats and one of the other things I
really like about this game is there's
so many like little fun things in this
game fritz it's like this weird vine
thing there's like a rune I didn't know
what it did like and there's a room that
you find that then lets you do stuff and
there's stuff in the background that you
can interact with but I haven't been
able to do anything with yet because I
just haven't unlocked that piece of the
game yet all right Aaron who do you
think would win a cage match an adult
lion or thirty little people a lion 100%
well it depends what are the people
armed with do you remember there was a
thing a while ago where it was like man
versus beast and it was like Michael
Phelps versus like a dolphin and like
you know a giraffe versus you know
whatever Kobayashi versus a bear who can
eat more hot dogs and the animals won
every single one I don't know if you've
seen there's a great YouTube video of
like five WWE wrestlers having a tug of
war with a mama lion and the mama lion
just pulls them all over so animals are
amazingly strong and crazy bet there's
room for the cow on the couch for you
now and II mutt says you can stay over
there that's okay that's fine okay do I
go toxic sewers Beth or do I go
Promenade of the condemned what do you
guys think
toxic sewers are Promenade of the
condemned oh the Promenade all right you
want to go out you've gone a little
promenade too or your Beth I don't know
Pete lacks charisma Conan or Aaron have
I don't know what you're talking about
Sandra but thank you dolphin yeah
animals win almost every time although
people are asking you got questions like
he's reading the chat shout out to me
please all right Russ man 3232 hey man
you know my brain is broken I can do two
things at once
Tom's place oh this is where the guy
from myspace lives now this is his place
prisoner and doctor of mushroom ology hi
but there's something here uh-oh a
hidden hole pinholes are always fun
secret zone so basically I mean here's
the thing we are basically sentient
mushrooms in this game yeah ooh I screen
eight I'll take that thank you
but the thing I love about this game
again is there's so many different
weapons so many modifiers this game
again is procedurally generated so every
time the level is different which is
just absolutely bananas and super fun
where am I going
let's go up here I can't recommend this
game enough and I don't like
side-scrollers I'm not I wasn't a
Castlevania fan hated Metroid but yet I
am obsessed with this game and play it
non-stop clueless gamers nothing without
air and Laird Marshawn Lynch I agree
Marshawn Lynch
nothing is anything without Marsha or
Sean is just he just makes you happy you
know I've told this story before but
after we did the first close gamer he
went to his car and got us all he drove
himself he went to his car and got to
give us all hats beastmode hats was
awesome
I'll take some brutality thank you hello
room service
oh oh oh these guys
yeah give me them sales baby him in
sales we're reading both chats meaning I
have other people reading them for me
lol BIM clock you may like path of Exile
with Hannah procedurally-generated it's
free but it's more like Diablo and
playstyle
I haven't played a lot of Diablo I
played like Diablo 3 which I don't think
people really consider true Diablo I
wouldn't jump past the shield there pal
watch in the back and they said never
kick a man when it's down I say it's
that much easier because your foot is
that much closer to face hello room
service yeah exactly
um yeah I might like path of Exile I
don't know I mean again like I'm not a
big blood-borne or Oh
shields get out of here with your
shields I say turn it up man let's get
aggressive I don't need shields I need
better weapons oh look what I have here
but I don't want any of these weapons I
feel I'm feeling pretty good with this
loadout but think about this game - is
the loadout is random so are there's the
promenade the condemned so when you get
some good weapons it's almost it's like
the best feeling because I've been
saddled with terrible weapons and you
just know I mean we have 10 cells which
is pretty good and you'll see her in a
second I'm of all the things I'm working
on but you get a good loadout it's the
best you get super far but don't give up
that's right baby
didn't play Diablo 3 but imagine if I
like Diablo 2 formula which I think path
of Exile does as well turn it up waffle
tarts and I'm talking about the interns
get paid no they don't but you have to
be getting college credit so these are
all the permanent upgrades and these
don't go away so what happens is between
levels you get these cells and you kind
of get to work on them so if I die again
it's not like the health last three goes
down to zero so that's what makes this
game super fun and addictive is you are
kind of grinding away at some permanent
stuff
so this victims burn do like that somes
frees other enemies freezes alright
perfect
alright hello we get a cool little bonus
here we got extra life that's always fun
fill up our health flask I'm acting like
teenagers your age I hope that's
thirteen because I consider myself like
a teenager you know so if I'm acting
like a teenager your age that means I'm
actually acting more mature than normal
right Beth okay she's over it and she
doesn't care she's like I can't believe
we have to do stream cocoa again it's
the worst
I do love games like this cuz it's like
who would make something or just these
things fly oh come on that was
[Music]
oh man look I got some sweet ice going
on over here
not a big chatter somebody be lurking
all right Matthew Nelson dead cells are
playing dead cells I think this is by
those guys are the worst
I laugh oh man I hate those guys I also
hate these things there's a lot of
things in this game I hate doesn't
matter of course Oh God I'm just getting
destroyed today
just don't act like a teenage girl why
not I love Taylor Swift she's the best
I'm now super nervous
ooh animal head okay who is this
something new do I get to find something
what's happening here
have I streamed oh I've seen 20xx oh you
talked about the new CD Projekt RED game
I've seen the trailer for that it looks
amazing
No nope nope nope
Oh where's the ice cream oh man Taylor
Swift isn't a teen yeah but like teens
listen to our music right or maybe
that's just me
I see hidden area guys cool there's a
weird bat thing in here
oh god this game to all that for daggers
who cares
the name of the game is in the title of
the live yeah it's dead cells come on
Aaron what is my favorite guests I've
had on on the show run stream cocoa my
favorite guests we've had on the show is
tough I mean on stream cocoa there's so
many good ones like I said I love when
the WWE people stop by is a really nice
and fun yeah I don't know it's tough I
mean I guess marina Franklin is great
anybody who's like I would say it's way
harder to pick a good guest because
we've had so many good guests on and
there's no real bad guest just bad host
cuz I'm a bad host alright do we want
this blood sword who do we want oh we
already have the blood sword forget it
forget it
it's a nice that's it's nice seeing you
not bullied by Conant well thank you
that's it's nice to not be bullied by
Cohn and honestly so with this you have
to kill this this weird gingerbread man
guy who's giving everybody their own oh
[Music]
come on
nope give me a chance to shoot the
arrows there we go finally ah I had to
use my heart this is tough a good hand
this game is to get two swords and click
both weapons simultaneously to get some
super fast oh wow okay that is a good
tip anybody else got good tips for this
game because I'm getting my ass handed
to me so if anybody else has great tips
I'd love to hear them I guess I gotta
take a health potion cuz this dude's
gonna kill me can't catch the
gingerbread man I'm tied with my feet
now that's Beth typing boom it's great
[Music]
take care of them slicer
[Music]
never have a safe night alright see you
there yeah that's ahead well play didn't
say is that I'm typing with my feet
that's true
hobbies types new feet she's really
Daniel day-lewis in it I guess that was
all him one foot there'd better be
something cool down here cuz there's a
lot of spikes cut to nothing cool down
here I know there's not gonna be
anything cool down here that's the way
this game breaks your heart man it makes
you work for a lot of oh alright don't
invite any guests we're clueless gamer
just you and Conan
the thing is Conan likes doing them with
celebrities so I would it's hurt it no
don't help Jesus God eat a dick eat a
dick Oh some jewels yeah it's he likes
doing celebrities so I think they're
probably gonna continue although we
might do one or two more with me I think
it kind of depends
that blood sword was highest-level dude
I had something that was the same level
Tim problem with procedurally generated
games yeah it kills you to ohm's all
toes are just thumbs wait what kind of
feets you have that you've thumbs on
your feet
oh yeah she has all pinky toes also Beth
has like a thousand teeth like your
shirt monster
council has dead cells on Matthew
Knutson it is on all consoles I believe
I know it's on switch and Xbox I believe
it's on I believe it's also on
PS where I'd be shocked if it wasn't
gingerbread man is killing us good tip
try not to get hit thank you
alright I'll do some tactics I'll take
care of some techniques these guys I
hate man I hate those dudes oh he
doesn't see me over here though boom get
me old ground smash Oh God
don't have my ice dang that sucks for me
I love it let the robots do the work you
know guys my extent for red gets you
very excited Red Dead is like one of my
favorite games of all time so I'm super
pumped I really hope they don't mess it
up I'm just
oh god here we go got it
Oh F gingerbread man can eat it dick
nope
let's try nice try nope cool do I
I might just nope nope nope nope nope
there we go getting out of a tight spot
some here play this game yeah if I
played fortnight I'm terrible in
fortnight I I'm really bad although I've
won a few games but it's really hard the
Commodore 64 thank you
no but Morgan they should why do they
stop making games for the Commodore 64
that's then I want to know this game
I've never been like a speed runner but
this game it's so well-balanced that it
makes you want to go super fast and I
read this great article about they had
this rule like the two second rule that
every battle should last two seconds and
if it's a closed weapon one second if
it's a if it's like a distance weapon
four seconds and that's it's true like
it's this game is really great at you
know you kill so many enemies it makes
you just want to keep going oh come on
unless of course you're fighting one of
these tables in case it makes you want
to give up on life
you got a lot of fans in Korea Oh
Brandon Kim I hope so
I love going to Korea was so fun we had
a blast there all right a lot of bats we
got to be getting to the end of this
level come on man
Oh see I don't have the thing where I
could jump super high yet I'm still
alive hey jugs what's up it's about
having watch the street for the past
hour I still know what's going on in
this game waffle tarts we are a sentient
fungus that's taken over a dead body and
you're you start in a prison you're
trying to escape this town basically so
it's kind of like a big jailbreak is the
idea Oh
blocks them from ice creams - that sucks
and so this game is procedurally
generated it's super fast and it's
permadeath so when you die you die for
good and there's a ton of great crazy
weapons and crazy guy crazy enemies in
this game and you just fly through it
it's super fun it's my current favorite
game I'm having a blast playing it I
played it over and over forever and you
cut that fun thing is you kind of
because it's procedurally generated you
get a different game every time but
there are some there's some really fun
level ups that you can get that are
permanent yeah does ascension on a
sentient fungus game another one of
those yeah that old story
exactly but it's cool and kind of as you
go through motion tween did a good job
of being smart about there is kind of a
little bit of a story you get so you do
learn a little bit of the history of
yourself which is cool I'm just working
on that health last three guys grinding
away
I think we're good with all these I'm
gonna go extra 30 HP Oh much love back
crown panda at Armenia you wouldn't hold
your breath I didn't see what it was the
lags I'm not sure this came free or do I
need to buy them and where can I get it
worsen and why it's I think it's like 20
bucks it's on all platforms it's
fantastic and super fun Oh can't open it
from here what oh I have one more
mutation oh that's cool
let's do the combo make sure you watch
the show tonight we've got marina
Franklin wolf who's on the show bill
bird the great bill bird and I love
Regina Hall as well Regina Hall bill
burr and the oh and marina Franklin
that's right
this is really fun mad squirrel I gotta
say and it's also like it's weird like
it's not these levels you discover it's
not super linear it kind of is but like
I just discovered this level a little
while ago and it doesn't lead to another
there's another level that you can't get
to unless you go through this one it's
kind of like a web do you know what I'm
talking about
also what is an ossuary is that a place
where birds are I'll tell you what it is
in this game a place where terrible
annoying
these things suck a lot of really
annoying bad guys in this level oh these
things I hate this game
these guys suck
let's go down here and kill this thing
what's a sentient goop I'm the only
sentient goop that gets to run around
these halls all right so down here what
have we got oh boy that thing that's fun
let's just toss one of these down there
see what happens
oh man it won't freeze a robot thing
Jesus Christ oh my god because really
fast for his size by the way very scary
I don't like that's why I don't like
cockroaches cuz there's so oh Jesus
Christ
I got a heel oh there's a clueless gamer
for Red Dead - yeah I'm working on it
don't worry
I also raised a container a room where
dead people or bones are placed all
right so it's basically like a bone
hotel a bone tell oh Jesus hahahaha
gotcha
nice man that eyescreen aid really comes
in handy ah
when I gotta get the messenger I don't
know what that is what is the messenger
I might get it
I'm not going here uh yeah I don't think
anybody likes cockroaches but me in
particular big things that move fast not
a fan not a thing I don't like small
things to move I don't really like
things that move fast how about that
I'll just shorten it to that
when's the $0.50 episode gonna be live
isn't it already it's up dude wow that
guy killed that thing quick I'm not
going up there
oh that hurts me that's it that hurts me
when I hit his shell that sucks
I'm more of a bird fan yeah the bird by
the way is gone yeah I haven't seen the
bird in a while I know the end of an era
man I was gonna do a whole thing where I
was gonna buy it there's a bird that was
just destroying my life for a long time
outside my apartment and was killing me
and I was gonna buy a whole puppet and
do a whole bird situation and then it
just it just disappeared so it screwed
me even then which sucks
not only did the bird annoy me for
basically four months it also didn't
even let me make fun of it worst thing
ever worst animal ever bird worse than
cockroaches a lot of cells why would why
would I do that why would I go up there
why would I do that that's the dumbest
thing ever go down dude wrong button
Jesus why am i hitting the DAAD button
this game freaks me out obviously cuz
I've screamed a couple times my charge
this channel narrow I'm not in charge of
anything
I am the low man on the totem pole I'm
so far down on the totem pole I'm like
beneath the ground I'm like the concrete
base actually speaking of oh it's one
minute away guys I think we're gonna
have to say goodbye because Tim Coco we
got to do a show so here we go let's
just go crazy oh my do you know what I
kind of want to keep my cell so I might
play for a few minutes once this is done
if that's okay with everybody
ah man I missed you in the cone where
the game review is not the celebs I know
man I know it sucks I would love to keep
doing them with Jimmy accounting but I
got to do what the boss wants and what
the boss wants is celebs those look like
little kind of dogs what dogs like a
shar-pei or something is that a kind of
dog
Oh God B yeah maybe for Red Dead to you
if we can get a gamer going on that
might be fun I love you too Godzilla and
I seen this train back it's nice to be
back waffle
oh god that was terrible
yeah let's climb down the chain slowly
great idea I will say one thing about
this level I like as things don't pop
out of the ground and you don't like
every other level order of the king um I
play a big role thank you very much I
already seen Doublemint Cry 5 no I
haven't I'm very into it I am addicted
to this game and II it's it's intense
it's fun I can't I can't recommend this
game enough it's my current obsession
it's my life it's all I have to live for
guys that's all I have in my whole life
it's very sad but very true I would
never lie to you a lot of running here
with no guys it's making me very nervous
about to die anyway might as well do
this can't take it with you
oh thanks Kyle I'm a big fan of yours
thank you for saying that that's very
nice oh Jesus Christ
oh cool that didn't work at all nice
thankfully there's a giant ledge over
here I can use
get him get him slicer can you imagine
how hard this game would be if these
guys could come down on this platform so
hard oh damn it alright well I mean good
timing I guess
thank you all for joining us it's a
super fun thanks for putting up with my
glasses
once again please watch the show tonight
bill burr Regina Hall marina Franklin
thank you to marina Franklin for
stopping by once more go to marina
Franklin comm out of see her in
Pittsburgh see of the Vic Theatre in
Chicago and see her in tonight's show
thank you all for joining us I think
we'll see you next week
and we'll see you next week right back
here I'm really gonna try to not play
dead cells next week but it might be
dead cells go get this game motion tween
great job in making this game I will see
you guys after Matthew Knutson Sarah
video ha like Richard hung well Clint
I'm a music team-up great name mr.
freakasaurus Michael Bianco see you guys
later watch the shot and I